we gotta talk about LeBron coming back
to the hometown baby that's a big deal
how are you feeling right now you got
Irie
you got ya Kyrie Irving I don't know why
I said I read but I'm thinking about
weed in my head right now
then God Wiggins you got wait maybe
maybe not we can maybe love but but how
do you feel about LeBron coming back man
you are mr. Cleveland
I'm just stoked at the city stoked I
mean I know it's like a politically
correct answer but were you like were
you like one of those really mad dudes
when he left
yeah I was pretty bummed yeah and while
was downtown and I performing at the
House of Blues so I saw all that oh yeah
I was it I was right in the midst of
that but he's a hometown kid yeah I mean
he's a great player at the end of day
two so to just have that on our team I
mean do the City deserve some happy
things that's what I think like this
album going to the Grammys I think I'm
pretty confident it's gonna make that
happen